U.S Regulators have given the green
light to the sale of lab-grown chicken
products at selected restaurants two
companies good meat and upside foods
have received approval lab-grown meat is
cultivated from animal cells in steel
tanks its proponents say it's a more
sustainable kind of meat production
better for both animals and the
environment the US is the second country
to approve lab-grown meat after
Singapore did so in 2020.
ultimately the cells do what they do
they like to double like they like to
grow and then ultimately they become
meat so after 7 to 14 days or a little
longer depending on what we're making we
harvest the cells and then we can make
it into any meat product that you love
so it could be a chicken filet it could
be a hamburger a hot dog it could be
pretty much anything that you can think
of
well Ricardo San Martin is director of
university for California
Berkeley's alternative alt Meats lab as
it's known and joins us now from
Berkeley good to have you with us
Professor live on Al Jazeera can we just
start with how feasible you think this
new technology is and is it a solution
to a long-term problem perhaps of meat
production
uh my response is based on
on very well-known fermentation science
and uh all the analysis we have done
here at the College of Engineering at
University of California Berkeley
indicate that unfortunately
um everything is against having
these cells and this meat production at
scale in an economical way
why does why does the scale or the
upscaling you might say of production
um not sort of add up as far as you're
concerned
oh the thing is the cells are living
organisms and have their limitations and
they depend like on the oxygen they
receive or the nutrients they're given
and they have limits to how many you can
grow in this experimenters and the
fermenters are very expensive and these
cells are animal cells prone to
contamination on viruses which makes a
biosafety at the cost and therefore the
investment in this kind of facilities is
very large it's in the hundreds of
millions of dollars and because of that
then uh it's although it's technically
feasible to produce them at small scale
is not economically feasible to produce
them at large scale what sort of
historical evidence is there that ideas
like this that require millions of
dollars for development don't actually
work in the end is there any
um example that you can give us
well when you're against nature there's
a very clear example and I I did all my
grad studies when I was young uh on this
topic which is the replacement of
gasoline or oil by ethanol that was in
the 1980s that was the major thing every
every country in the Western countries
were investing on and so hundreds of
millions of dollars were dedicated to
obtain sugars from
forests and don't make those sugars with
uh yeast make them ethanol and run carbs
until this day this had been impossible
to do and that's because of the nature
and the complexity of
the shapes and forms of what Nature has
done sometimes science has a weird way
of finding other solutions by accident
do you think there is a practical
application for the technology that's
being used that could be used in another
positive way way
it could be used as the companies
they're claiming at making an expensive
ingredient let's say fat cells to add to
plant-based matrices and then then you
could by doing that you could impart
flavor or you can impart texture to
plant-based Foods so that's a way of
lowering the costs but there's no way
you can do like let's say a chicken
fillet at the cost of reasonable cost
uh with these Technologies do you think
though that I say you know U.S
Regulators have given the green light to
this technology and to this development
do you believe that governments and
researchers have to take a chance you
have to try something out to see whether
it's going to work or not
you have to I'm a scientist myself and
you know I belong to the College of
Engineering of UC Berkeley so there's no
way we can we are going to face the
problems we're facing of uh growth human
growth and climate change without
technology but you have to do a clear
assessment and differentiate between
what can technology can do because of
its limit of the boundaries it has with
a business in what you're probably
listening is is the business narrative
and you can probably make you know a
small business out of that profitable
but that's not a game-changing solution
to to replacing meat with this kind of
development it's a very expensive
development all these companies are
thinking of you know hundreds of
millions of dollars to create facilities
that would only replace you know a few
thousand animals it'll be interesting to
see how this does uh move forward but
for the moment we'll leave it there
Ricardo San Martin from the University
University of California thanks so much
for joining us on Al Jazeera sir